hola bienvenidos a la entrevista de
france 24 en español en esta oportunidad
nos acompaña ricardo césar pérez
manrique el ex presidente de la corte
interamericana de derechos humanos un
mandato de dos años que comenzó el
primero de enero de este 2002 y que
culminará el 31 de diciembre de 2023
ricardo pérez manrique muchísimas
gracias por su presencia en transmití 4
gracias a ustedes por la invitación un
gusto acompañado el gusto es nuestro
ricardo usted ha dicho que los próximos
dos años van a ser muy especiales sobre
todo según sus propias palabras porque
en la región hay una suerte de un
progresivo deterioro en algunos aspectos
de los sistemas democráticos algo que se
conoce como democracias imperfectas
podría desarrollar esta idea
el continente
y he hecho en los últimos años en
algunos países una deriva autoritaria y
en otros países se ha dado un fenómeno
en el cual gobernantes electos por el
voto popular intentan perpetuarse en el
poder mediante modificaciones
institucionales también apreciamos
dificultades para que las personas sean
realmente sientan realmente que la
democracia es el sistema en el cual los
problemas son atendidos y sus problemas
son resueltos
creo que las últimas movilizaciones
populares que han visto han habido en la
región
algunas con alto nivel de violencia
demuestra esa insatisfacción de las
personas no encontraron que su situación
que su posición que sus necesidades
atendidas por los gobernantes y además
eso en estos dos años van a ver
elecciones clave en el continente todo
eso hace que el panorama sea complejo
ahora hablando un poco del
funcionamiento del organismo la corte y
dh recibe a través de lo que es la
comisión interamericana
humanos denuncias por eventuales
violaciones a los derechos humanos
cometidas supuestamente por los estados
le propongo un repaso por algunos temas
que en la región son focos de conflicto
para conocer cómo llegan a la corte y
también por supuesto en qué estado de
situación se encuentran y uno de los
temas implícitos en lo que la violación
a los derechos fundamentales atañe a los
migrantes no en algunos países de la
región se agudiza muchísimo lo que es la
precariedad la falta de garantías para
miles de ellos donde encuentra hoy usted
los puntos más conflictivos y qué
acciones recomienda a los diferentes
estados
yo encuentro
tu encuentro que las violaciones a los
derechos humanos en el contexto de
migración se
profundizan y se hacen sumamente graves
la corte ha dictado dos directivas sobre
el
2008 sobre migrantes nota 2 la de 2000
cortes por equipos ni asesores de
movilidad y recientemente en el 2020
hemos dictado medidas provisionales
relativas al estado de panamá exigiendo
que adoptará y adoptará políticas
tendientes a proteger a la league ante
los problemas derivados de vides y
darles garantías respecto a esta luz
física y mental física y al biólogo
también debo señalar que estas medidas
para la corte no sólo corresponden
exclusivamente algunos a un estado sino
que son medidas deben ser
afrontadas
en el contexto general de la de la
cooperación internacional porque hay
varios estados involucrados pero
seguimos hablando ahora de otros puntos
críticos no vinculados a las violaciones
a los derechos humanos en américa
hablemos ahora de la violencia de género
miles de mujeres mueren cada año son
múltiples muchísimos los casos de
denuncias a hombres que luego terminan
asesinando las casos también con medidas
como por ejemplo de restricciones
perimetrales que terminan siendo
violadas con las propias denunciantes
finalmente asesinadas denuncias también
de maltratos a las mujeres por parte de
las fuerzas de seguridad cuando van a
hacer sus denuncias desde muchos
sectores están apuntando a riccardo a la
necesidad de reformas judiciales pero
con perspectivas de género hay así una
deuda pendiente creo usted y una
necesidad
y yo creo que es un fenómeno muy
complejo
pienso que la cuestión del acceso a la
justicia de las mujeres víctimas de
violencia de género así como
otros tipos de violencia de género que
se dan respecto de otros colectivos como
las protestas ha dictado sentencias en
el caso del asesinato de la mujer trans
escasos y que hernández duras y el caso
de azul roja pero es que en caso de
detención y torturas y arbitrariedades
un hombre gay ha generado en la corte
una serie de estándares que tienen que
ver con cambios que son imprescindibles
para que estos grupos vulnerables tengan
la protección necesaria insisto en la
cuestión de la violencia de género
también tiene un altísimo contenido
cultural que hay que trabajar en los
aspectos educativos y qué
hay un gran imperativo en esto que es
involucrarnos los hombres los varones
involucrarnos como partes centrales del
problema que somos y convertirnos en
parte del problema y no convertirnos en
actores activos valga la redundancia
solución de este problema hay que
empoderar a los hombres para
buscar también ellos nosotros contra la
violencia de género muy interesante ese
punto al que hace referencia a ricardo y
otro tema que está en debate en
muchísimos países con realidades muy
diferentes con diversos matices por
supuesto y con algunas naciones como por
ejemplo el caso de el salvador con casos
graves en el centro de la polémica es el
derecho a la salud reproductiva y en
particular al aborto desde su propia
perspectiva hacia donde deberían avanzar
los países de la región en materia de
salud reproductiva
si la corte dictó recientemente una
sentencia en un caso emblemático del
salvador el caso denominado manuela en
el cual una mujer que había que tuvo un
parto a término con problemas de
compartimiento del feto fue finalmente
condenada a 30 años de cárcel y al año y
medio falleció por no haber sido
atendida en prisión su salud creo que
esta cuestión de lo que se llama la pues
las políticas reproductivas el aborto
etc etc conforman la necesidad de pensar
en un mundo en el cual las personas
tienen autonomía en el cual las personas
pueden tener tomar decisiones y al
respecto de ese mundo el estado debe ser
un factor que permita a las personas ser
más libres permite a las personas
adoptar sus decisiones y hacerse cargo
de sus decisiones y no un estado que
aparece
desarrollando políticas personalistas en
realidad lo que hacen es dejar al
gobernante de arbitrador de soluciones
que son muy complejas del vista humano
del punto de vista filosófico moral
político y hasta religioso hablábamos
hace minutos de lo que es la violencia
que sufren las mujeres verdad hablemos
ahora de otros sectores de la población
me refiero en particular de los ataques
en contra de la comunidad lgtb de kumasi
la corte se ha pronunciado sobre hechos
sobre varios hechos como por ejemplo
bueno recientemente el asesinato de una
líder trans en honduras cómo describiría
en términos de derechos humanos la
situación que vive este colectivo
este es un colectivo vulnerable
que tiene además especiales condiciones
de vulnerabilidad porque su propio
nombre con cinco siglas demuestra que es
un colectivo
variopinto con distintas perspectivas y
cada perspectiva consume tiene sus
particularidades y esto vuelvo a repetir
es un desafío hacia la diversidad un
desafío sea la pluralidad hacia prensa
hacia para pensar en sociedades en que
todos más allá de nuestras
características personales tenemos no
sólo nuestra ubicación sino que también
tenemos un espacio para crecer un
espacio para participar un espacio a los
efectos de realizar
el ideal del ser humano que es la vida
en sociedad de la vida en familia la
posibilidad de tener un trabajo etcétera
todo lo que cualquiera de nosotros
siente que necesita como ser humano hay
que asegurarle a estas personas que
comen con éstos
y colectivos que finalmente es pequeño
que tiene un alto nivel de
vulnerabilidad es asegurar que estos
derechos puedan ser puedan ser realmente
gozados ejercidos ejemplo en este caso
en el de honduras le acreditó que en la
expectativa de vida de vida de una mujer
trans es de 34 años de 34 años de edad y
esa vida se tronchan generalmente de
manera violenta o por la vía de las
enfermedades pero esta perspectiva tiene
que llamarlos actuar sobre ese problema
y buscarle soluciones
riccardo hablemos ahora de otro tema
crítico para la región me refiero al
sistema carcelario hay cárceles
superpobladas plagadas de todo tipo de
violencia muchísimas sin recursos como
garantizar en este contexto la
reinserción social de los reclusos
la corte ha definido a lo largo de su
trayectoria
una serie de parámetros de lo que debe
ser la obligación del estado frente a
privado de libertad a idea desarrolló la
noción de garantía es decir el estado es
el único responsable sobre la integridad
personal a la integridad física la
posibilidad de realización social de una
persona que ha privado de libertad por
una decisión del propio estado entonces
esta obligación garantía
recta de garantía para la zona de
libertad está en el centro de la
cuestión carcelaria pero para mí lo que
es fundamental en toda política
carcelaria es crítica punitiva del
estado' el estado desarrollo y
desarrollo si el estado es una pista
punitiva que tiende a nada más la visión
cada vez no actúa sobre el equipo
indudablemente la que se convierte en
verdadero tiernos los cuales el estado
no tienes esto cuando en donde hay
crimen organizado el crimen organizado
de ir a las acciones con las cosas más
espeluznantes esta materia de motines y
eso es lo que evitar con una política
entre los criminales con políticas
sociales pesadas y también obviamente
con un estado que
visualiza esto un problema capital
porque yo siempre planteó los pienses si
yo tengo una esta política carcelaria y
yo recupero a la el estado recupera la
cuando salgan en libertad no buena y
desde entonces la política que haría es
una parte esencial del punto de vista la
ciudad y el discurso que le trasmite a
las personas como es exactamente el
mundo absolutamente a ricardo césar
pérez manrique muchísimas gracias por su
presencia en france 24
muchísimas gracias a ustedes que
quedamos a las órdenes gracias a usted
normalmente a nuestra audiencia como
siempre le invitamos a seguir
informándose en france 24 y en france
mit y cuatro.com sigan con nosotros
[Música]
y